PAUL IRISH: Hi, I'm Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Hi, I'm Paul.
PAUL IRISH: We're going to
be taking a look at the
performance of your sites
and apps that you've
submitted to us.
PAUL LEWIS: Now, we've
taken a very quick
look at some of them.
But we haven't spent that long
doing it, just so that we can
show you how we kind of come
at these things fresh.
PAUL IRISH: So we're going to be
doing an audit of both the
page load time--
PAUL LEWIS: --and
the run time.
PAUL IRISH: And--
PAUL LEWIS: Well, let's
get on with i.
PAUL IRISH: OK, cool.
So these were the sites
that you submitted.
And let's just-- we're going
to just take a few of them.
So the first one to come
up is myunidays.
Uh, Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes?
PAUL IRISH: I know that
you took a look.
And it looked interesting.
PAUL LEWIS: It did.
It did.
PAUL IRISH: Want
to drive this?
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
So step one always for these
things, for me at least, is to
do a timeline.
So go into DevTools.
Hit Timeline.
Go to frames mode.
And you can hit Command
E, which should
start things recording.
And then normally, I'll just
do a bit of a scroll test,
maybe interact with a few
things, just kind of get the
sense of what's going on.
And oh, you've got an unusual
keyboard now.
How do we get back
to-- there we go.
PAUL IRISH: There we go.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
That's good.
Now um--
PAUL IRISH: So what
do we see here?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, so the first
thing that we really, really
care about is the fact that
we've got this 60 frames a
second line and then the 30
frames a second line.
And you can see that that's
on the right hand
side of the top part.
Now we never want our bars to
go above the 60 frames a
second line.
This is kind of super
critical.
If we want a 60 frames a
second app, which we
do, never go above.
Now you can see, we are
obviously going way above on
some of these.
So just by clicking in the
timeline, you start to figure
out what's actually going on.
Now this is the thing that
really started to bother me,
which is this little exclamation
mark what you can
see on the left hand side.
So if we spin this--
oh.
PAUL IRISH: Just click
around here.
There you go.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
Spin this down.
You can see that we get
some recalc style,
and we get some layout.
And you can see that there's
this little exclamation mark
on the left hand side.
And that's basically-- when you
roll over the exclamation
mark, you see this note. "Forced
synchronous layout is
a possible performance
bottleneck."
Now what's really happening here
is we've forced Chrome to
answer a question about the
dimension or the position of
an element when it wasn't
really expecting to.
So it has to go off, and it has
to lay out a whole of the
page-- probably, in this case--
plus the partial scope.
So not the whole page, but it
still had to do some work that
it didn't expect to
do in layout.
Then the next we're actually
going to do is probably change
some style, recalculate.
Recalculate style suggests that
we then change things.
And that invalidated the
previous calculation we did.
So then we lay out against.
So this is called layout
thrashing.
And it's this idea of stepping
back and forth, going layout,
change some styles, layout,
change some styles.
PAUL IRISH: You'll see it--
it'll commonly-- in the
DevTools, it'll visualize as a
number of just purple bars,
just a big kind
of cascade of purple.
Often-- and on the left hand
side, you'll see a kind of
recalc val layout going
back and forth.
And hopefully, this little arrow
indicating that yeah,
this is a problem.
PAUL LEWIS: Now, don't be
confused by the fact that it's
often wrapped in a yellow bar.
It's triggered by JavaScript.
But it's not JavaScript.
Right?
PAUL IRISH: Right.
PAUL LEWIS: It can be triggered
by CSS as well.
But it's the fact that when
it was in here, it was
triggered--
wherever it was.
I forget now.
PAUL IRISH: So next, what we can
do is we can take a look
at the actual code
of what happens.
So we have a few options
for doing this.
We can just click ahead in right
here on the link for all
JS line number 21.
So let's do that.
OK.
So line number 21 is
the remainder of
the minified jQuery.
So we'll use the prettify
function down here.
[HUMMING]
All right.
Now come back.
And so what we'll see--
let's take a look
at this again.
Oh, no.
I'm going to record
another timeline.
I'll just scroll like this.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Come back over, pick
a long frame, go inside.
PAUL LEWIS: Still doesn't
like a bit-- does
the stack trace change?
PAUL IRISH: No.
What?
Chrome Canary.
Come on!
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
PAUL IRISH: So what I'd
like to see is--
what you'll normally catch in
this case is-- you'll catch an
instance where the pretty print
will adjust all the line
numbers for the entire
call stack.
This means that after your
pretty print, you can dive
into the original location more
or less and figure out
what the story is.
But the interesting part here is
that we're going to be able
to not only see kind of where
this came-- so let's try it
once more, pretty print, and
come back to timeline.
PAUL LEWIS: Hey!
So this is stable.
He switched to Stable, in case
you didn't notice that.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, yeah,
Chrome Stable.
All right.
So now we have a line
number of 3835.
So if we click through
on this--
so we're inside of jQuery.
PAUL LEWIS: What do you know?
Offset width, offset height.
These are kind of classic
candidates for something--
obviously, this is something
that jQuery is using, which is
perfectly reasonable to use.
But it's something that--
when you ask for the offset
width or the offset height,
Chrome's going to have
to go off and
figure out the for that.
Right?
PAUL IRISH: Right.
And so if we want to figure out
why this happened, we can
look at the call stack
of this layout.
And so typically, what you're
going to be looking at is this
Layout Forced section
down here.
Now this is the location that
forced that layout.
In our case, it is that offset
width, offset height.
But we can walk back
to call stack.
See, we're inside jQuery,
jQuery, jQuery.
But we get back to here,
Get Size Info.
Here on Get Size Info, we're
able to basically--
whoops.
Let me try that again.
I just want to make sure that
this is big enough for
everyone to see.
How about--
there we go.
PAUL LEWIS: How are
we doing now?
PAUL IRISH: There we go.
Looking good.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So Get Size Info, don't
think it's jQuery.
I'll click over to it in here.
All right.
So Get Size Info, we get
the view port width.
We grab the wrapper.
We walk up its parent
chain twice.
And we get the width
of that parent.
And so it looks like Get Size
Info is actually being called
inside of tick.
And tick is being called
how often?
PAUL LEWIS: Every two
seconds, maybe.
Maybe more.
2,000, there we go.
PAUL IRISH: Every two seconds.
So that's--
[INAUDIBLE] intervals.
PAUL LEWIS: Because we figured
this-- is this part of the
carousel or something
like that?
Do we know?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, scroll
up a little bit.
I think--
PAUL LEWIS: There we go,
function carousel.
So there's a carousel
on this site
ticking every two seconds.
It's kind of going into layout
thrashing for whatever reason.
Yeah, it's probably that one.
PAUL IRISH: There are a
few carousels there.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, there
are a few carousels.
OK.
So it's probably several
carousels
that are causing this.
So you're always probably in
some kind of recalc layout
thrashing kind of mode at
some points or other.
PAUL IRISH: Right.
In this case, there
are a few options.
It's likely that actually the
width of that parent parent
probably isn't going
to be changing.
You can-- so if you're seeing
this, and you want to avoid
this time spent layout
thrashing, you want to be able
to cache these values,
hold on to them.
So you don't need to go back and
re-query the DOM while the
browser is trying to paint
updates to the user.
You want to just let
it paint updates.
And so give it all the
truth ahead of time.
PAUL LEWIS: If it is a
responsive site, then you
probably want to do it in things
like the resize handler
or something like that, just
somewhere where you can
actually say, look, I'm only
carrying when you actually
definitely resize this stuff.
PAUL IRISH: So I
would disagree.
PAUL LEWIS: Ooh, where
would you put it?
PAUL IRISH: [LAUGHS]
PAUL LEWIS: That's fine.
What'd you do it in? rAF?
PAUL IRISH: I did it in rAF.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, he's
just doing it--
OK, fair enough.
Do the [INAUDIBLE] and just set
a rAF inside your resize
handler, at which point
you'll pick up the--
PAUL IRISH:
requestAnimationFrame.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
That's fine.
PAUL IRISH: So actually,
I want to
spend a moment on this.
Resize events.
There's only a few things that
you should ever do inside of a
resize event or a
scroll event.
Let's take scroll because
it's a little bit more
common of an example.
Inside a scroll event, you can
ask for, let's say, get the
scroll top, the scroll
top metric.
You ca also ask for the
time, probably.
And that's about it.
You do not want to do any other
work inside the handler.
So minimizing the amount of work
that you're doing in the
handler, do the work that you
actually have to do inside of
requestAnimationFrame.
So that's where you're going
to do your work.
And what this allows the
browser to do is--
it gets out of scroll.
When you bind a scroll, what it
means is that when a person
puts their finger down on the
site, on your site, and
scrolls the page like that,
everything that you have bound
to a scroll handler means--
it has to execute that before it
can even update the page to
scroll it, reacting to
that finger move.
PAUL LEWIS: The other thing
is you might actually get
multiple scroll events
per frame.
Right?
So if you're doing work in the--
you only probably care
about the last one.
Right?
PAUL IRISH: Right.
PAUL LEWIS: And the other things
you want to do is if
you do this debouncing--
which is what it's often
referred to as--
you want to make sure that you
don't shed your multiple
requestAnimaitonFrame
call backs.
So you want to make
sure that--
however many scrolls you've got,
you just say, look, just
set requestAnimaitonFrame call
back, store the value.
OK?
And then inside that
requestAnimationFrame call
back, you say, well, what was
the most recent value?
Now do my visual updates and
paint to the screen.
PAUL IRISH: This is something
that's really important if
you're doing any sort of
scrolling parallax site.
There are a few parallax
scripts that
do this exact technique.
Stellar.js, I know
is one of them.
But this is something to
watch out for, to make
sure that you do.
Otherwise, the performance of
the scrolling in the parallax
is going to be really poor.
They can get bad.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Shall we roll on?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, let's
take a look.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So I've got a few more here.
There's one up here at the
top I want to take
a quick look at.
So this Voos.
It is a big, big
Wordpress site.
They are using mod_pagespeed
already.
Awesome.
What else can we do?
So I opened this up earlier.
It's taking a while right now.
Actually, the domain was
br.staticcontent.
So I think actually--
we're in London.
It's coming over the
wire from Brazil.
So transfer time is going
to take a while.
CDN would help for us, but
not help for Brazilians.
So all right.
So it's a pretty basic
site here.
So other than going into the
interaction speed of these
form controls--
but I thought it would be
interesting to look at it from
a network perspective.
So I went to a WebPagetest just
before I started recording.
A I dropped Voos in here.
And WebPagetest usually
only takes a few.
Minutes
PAUL LEWIS: But you changed
the location, right?
For up to--
PAUL IRISH: Oh, I did, yeah.
So you can actually just say
in here what the test
location should be.
And there's locations
all over the globe.
So if you want to get kind of a
real world, over the network
experience--
PAUL LEWIS: So you set it to
Buenos Aires, so Argentina,
which is not so far away.
It's still in South America.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
So it's a little bit nearer.
So it's not skewed by our
London-ness right now.
PAUL IRISH: Yes, yes, yes.
So this is the report.
And so WebPagetest is going
to give us a lot of data.
And one of the most important
things is the waterfall.
I'll show right after it.
This is the connection view.
This is pretty rad.
So you'll have--
so it looks at TCP
connections.
Sometimes a browser will share
the same TCP pipe.
So actually it requested a
JavaScript file on a single
connection and then another
JavaScript file to share in
the exact same one.
This can be helpful sometimes.
But a lot of time, what you're
looking at is the waterfall.
Now, so this at the very
top is just the
HTML that comes in.
You can see we're
taking a while.
We're waiting on the server.
But then it's downloading
here.
But what I notice immediately
is I noticed a lot of
JavaScript up at the top.
So search box helper, functions,
jQuery, jQuery
templating plug-in.
And since these are
up at the top--
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, because
you'd expect--
if this was in flow, you'd
expect all the images,
everything else.
And then best practice is
JavaScript at the end, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
So let's take a look.
So we hop over.
We view source.
[HUMMING]
Find, I like just
bracket script.
PAUL LEWIS: Make it bigger
for everybody.
PAUL IRISH: Here we go.
Actually, the most
important thing--
it's probably hard to see.
But way over here on the right
is the scroll bar.
And you can see, there's a lot
of matches in my scroll bar in
the very top right, whereas
there's not matches at the
bottom as much.
But so if we look up here on
the top, you can see, yup.
Here's all the scripts
in the head.
And so we have jQuery and then
templating plug-in, base, all
these things.
So a browser is going to have
to request and complete
execution of all of these files
before it even starts to
show this sort of content
to a user.
That's just how it works.
This could be mitigated
potentially with async
attribute up here.
But generally, the best practice
is to throw all the
scripts at the bottom,
of course.
Concat as much as you can.
So that is the obvious
thing that I see
from WebPagetest waterfall.
Anything else?
It looks like there's flag
images that are sprited.
PAUL LEWIS: That's usually
a good thing.
PAUL IRISH: Good thing.
So the comment actually says
that mod_pagespeed is enabled.
mod_pagespeed by default is
actually not too aggressive.
So I would take a look at
configuring a few more filters
to be turned on by default.
One of my favorites
is around images.
There is a lot of
images of stuff.
But yeah.
Here, this one at the top.
This is rewrite_images.
So mod_pagespeed is a module for
Apache, also available for
EngineX, which is rad.
This rewrite_images
does a few things.
It in-lines images.
So if an image is under some
threshold, it'll just do it as
a data URI.
PAUL LEWIS: So we've now
removed the additional
request, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yup, absolutely.
It'll recompress images,
losslessly recompress them to
be even smaller than
they should be.
PAUL LEWIS: How does
it do that?
PAUL IRISH: Sorry.
Losslessly--
it's the same quality,
visually.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, OK.
PAUL IRISH: Get rid of
excess stuff that
doesn't need to be there.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
Right.
Does it transcode?
PAUL IRISH: Um, no.
PAUL LEWIS: Is that a
different filter?
PAUL IRISH: Different filter.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
So you've actually got options
of just optimizing your images
on the fly, but not transcoding
them over to, say,
WebP or-- assuming you've
started with PNT or JPEG.
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
And resize_images,
which is pretty.
So resize_images will take
effect if you have an inline
width or height attribute
on the image tag
or an inline style.
It will resize the image to fit
natively as that size that
the page is requesting
it be in.
PAUL LEWIS: I like it.
PAUL IRISH: Really powerful.
So that gives you all those
things for free.
So if you are digging into
mod_pagespeed or index page
speed, which you should, it does
all this work for you.
So your build script does
not have to be as crazy.
Dig into these filters, try
some out because there's a
lot, a lot power in there.
PAUL LEWIS: I think that's
really good to point that just
by having pagespeed step
one, but step two--
PAUL IRISH: Definitely.
PAUL LEWIS: Step two
is definitely
look at those filters.
So they're not just a kind
of-- and you're done.
PAUL IRISH: Yup.
Yup.
What's next?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL LEWIS: Do you want
to meet the Ipsums?
PAUL IRISH: Meet the Ipsums.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, let's
meet the Ipsums.
PAUL IRISH: Let's do it.
PAUL LEWIS: This is a great
little site, very amusing to
me, this whole site, different
forms of lorem ipsum.
This one is featuring cat ipsum
and veggie ipsum, so
celery, seakale, all these
different kinds of veggies,
corporate ipsum.
I like this one.
I've worked in those kind of
environments for a while.
PAUL IRISH: That's nice.
PAUL LEWIS: So I was
looking at this.
And I thought, this is great.
It's a really clean,
simple site.
And so I was busy looking at
the time, as I always do.
So I did a run.
And then I was just scrolling
just like that.
And it kind of felt janky.
And I was like, but why?
And then--
so paint is a thing.
PAUL IRISH: Yup.
Big thing.
PAUL LEWIS: It's a big thing.
And you can see here, it's--
I mean, you can't see Chrome
so much in the background.
But as you roll over this
record, you actually see a
blue area highlighted in Chrome,
which is kind of--
it's the area that had
to be repainted.
And looking at the size
of this thing--
1526 by 882--
it's like, that's big.
We want to reduce paint size
and paint complexity.
And I'm thinking paint size is
a good first start here.
Spin it down.
There's a couple of paints in
here that we can look at.
And yeah, there's a couple
of smaller ones.
But clearly, there's
this big paint.
So I'm thinking, well, this
is just scrolling.
It doesn't seem to
be doing much.
I get to end of the page and
there's this fixed position
element at the background.
Now--
PAUL IRISH: Now one thing that I
was wondering-- so normally,
a paint, when you scroll, at
least on desktop, the paint
will just happen at
the bottom, right?
As I'm scrolling, the paint
will supplement the new
content as that comes in?
PAUL LEWIS: It is going
to paint whatever--
yeah.
So if you're scrolling, yes.
It's exactly-- if you're up or
down, it depends on which end
of the-- the page needs
to be kind of handled.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah But what
we're seeing here is
that this paint is--
you can see kind of this
blue highlight.
It is the entire page.
And then this one again,
the entire page.
PAUL LEWIS: Now the reason for
this is most likely that
Chrome is looking at all the
styles of all the elements,
and it's grouping that fixed
position element with the
content that's scrolling.
So as it scrolls, the that fixed
position element needs
to be repainted so that it can
fill up the view port.
And then the scrolling content
sits over the top.
So it's almost like it's
pointless because-- it's just
one of these things, definitely
looking at ways
that we can make this better.
The fix for it, if you're
interested, would be to go
into the elements and would be
to promote the footer, which
is this fixed--
you can see it over here,
position fixed.
Would be to promote this
to its own layer.
So that basically, all the
compositor has to do is just
leave that there.
And the scrolling content
can move over the
top in its own layer.
And the simplest way to
do that that I know--
whoops, put that back--
is to use the 3D transform.
So use it sparingly.
But this is a classic case for
it, where we're painting
something on every frame,
something that doesn't need to
be repainted.
So let's do that web
kit transform.
Why not?
PAUL IRISH: Say it with
the [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: TranslateZ.
PAUL IRISH: [SNAPS FINGERS]
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
that's right.
It's so catchy.
I mean, I've even caught
my non-nerdy wife
talking about this.
No, I haven't really.
It's a lie.
PAUL IRISH: [LAUGHS]
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
So I've translated it.
Does it look any different?
Maybe, maybe not.
Let's find out.
Let's do a test and see what
happens when we scroll.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, that
looks nice.
PAUL LEWIS: So now we've much
reduced our paint costs.
Now there are things
going on here.
But that's the main thing
in this right now.
PAUL IRISH: Can we take a look
at this with Show Paint
Rectangles?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Are we going to
see a difference between
before and after that?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
So we don't need to do anything
other than-- we can
toggle the style on and off.
So what that'll do is-- we'll
pop down onto the cog here.
We can switch on Show
Paint Rectangles.
And we do that.
That's all we need to do.
And [INAUDIBLE], let's
just close.
Yeah, thank you.
You know all the shortcuts.
Aw.
PAUL IRISH: Escape.
PAUL LEWIS: Is that
what it is?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
there you go.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, I feel better
for knowing that.
Finding that out on air!
That's good.
It's good to go.
So what I need to do is I need
to go back to the elements.
I need to switch off
my translateZ.
Now when I scroll, you'll see
that whole thing is bright
red, as is the scroll bar
on the right hand side.
And that's just Chrome saying,
you know what?
These are the things
I have to paint.
So the scroll bar makes
perfect sense.
That's normal.
But seeing that whole thing,
oh, that's not so good.
So when we switch on the
translateZ, and we push that
out to its own layer-- that
background out to its own
layer-- what's going to actually
happen, is the
content that's sitting on
the top is also going
to get its own layer.
But we basically have
separated them out.
We kind of forced Chrome's
hand a little bit.
And now when we scroll--
PAUL IRISH: There it is.
PAUL LEWIS: There we go.
So using Show Paint Rectangles
or even just DevTools, you'll
find that you'll actually see
when things are painting.
And that's actually-- yeah.
PAUL IRISH: [MAKES GUN SOUNDS]
PAUL LEWIS: So you can see--
yeah, including sound effects.
When you get to the top,
obviously this is--
again, it makes sense for
this to probably--
PAUL IRISH: Oh, oh, oh.
PAUL LEWIS: But they
could probably--
PAUL IRISH: Another
opportunity.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, there is
another opportunity.
Instead of, I'm guessing, 2D
transforms here, if it were
me, I'd look at 3D
transforms again.
These are the things that don't
want to interact with
each other.
They just want to move around.
They want their own layer.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
We need two disclaimers here,
two separate disclaimers.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
I like disclaimers.
PAUL IRISH: OK, the first
one, you kind of
wrote about, I think.
I'm just going to guess--
PAUL LEWIS: There it is.
It just--
I--
PAUL IRISH: --layer
promotion, maybe.
PAUL LEWIS: Try it.
Let's see.
PAUL IRISH: All right, yeah.
OK, cool.
It's a part of this blog post
about the layer promotion
translateZ, translate3d hack.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
It's actually one of about six
or seven rules that Chrome
will use when it's
deciding to put
something on its own layer.
And translateZ is the most
well known of the family.
PAUL IRISH: And so it is a
hack.k and we feel interesting
about recommend it.
And this article explains some
of the downsides and some of
the things that you need
to be aware of.
It's not just a silver bullet.
It has downsides.
So read this.
And the other disclaimer,
I think, is about
cross-browserness.
Of all the things that we're
talking about today--
PAUL LEWIS: This is the least
cross-browser thing, right?
PAUL IRISH: Is it?
PAUL LEWIS: Because it's
not going to--
PAUL IRISH: Oh, yeah.
Even Chrome on Android,
it really
doesn't do these things.
PAUL LEWIS: Chrome on Android
and also word on the street is
that Safari no longer honors
it as a layer creation, or
certainly won't do
in the future.
And it's not-- you know, it's
a webkit prefixed thing, so
it's not going to
work in Firefox.
PAUL IRISH: But the networked
stuff that we should before,
absolute cross-browser.
Layout thrashing--
the way that the specs are
written for HTML recalculation
style, browsers have a
lot of consistency
between how they work.
So layout thrashing is
real everywhere.
PAUL LEWIS: It's called
reflow in Firefox.
PAUL IRISH: Reflow, yeah.
It's the exact same thing.
And so when you see reflow as
a term, it's this issue.
So it's a cross-browser
situation.
Anything else?
Expensive paints.
Expensive paints can be--
it's hard to say.
And right now, there's--
for what's expensive to
paint in Firefox and
IE is a little unclear.
We're hoping to find out
more about that.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
I think that's the thing.
I mean, you have
to profile it.
It's not always easy to do that
in a cross-browser way.
And you obviously don't want
to do anything that is an
anti-pattern elsewhere.
But generally speaking,
not painting is a
good pattern for everybody.
Not paintings is not painting,
irrespective of your browser.
So it's a good thing.
Do you want to hear
another one?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
I want to show you this one.
Whew.
OK.
Let's take a look.
All right.
So--
PAUL LEWIS: Oh wow, yeah.
PAUL IRISH: There's a bit
of load time right here.
Is that slow?
I'm just going to bump that into
a WebPagetest while we
kind of wait for it.
PAUL LEWIS: It's like
two tests in one.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Let's go for it.
We'll use--
oh, what's up?
PAUL LEWIS: Sounds like
it's got sound.
PAUL IRISH: We've got
sound coming here.
I'm going to turn it off just
because-- whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Chill out, guys.
All right.
We're in the front
of the queue.
Good.
Go back.
What do we do?
PAUL LEWIS: Click.
PAUL IRISH: Click.
PAUL LEWIS: And then
you hit the--
I think it's--
PAUL IRISH: OK.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, try
using-- there we go.
OK, now you roll your
mouse around and--
now I don't know if you can
see this on the video, but
this is hideously janky.
This is really bad.
PAUL IRISH: This was submitted
by someone who wanted us to
talk about it.
I mean--
PAUL LEWIS: Sorry.
PAUL IRISH: I feel like you're
being a bit mean here.
PAUL LEWIS: I mean, this is
taking upwards of a second to
update the screen.
PAUL IRISH: These
are Voronois.
There's a Voronoi
map behind it.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
So let's take a look at why.
All right.
So I'm going to Command Option
I into DevTools.
We're going to head into
Timeline soon.
Come on.
Play nice.
PAUL LEWIS: You making it mad?
PAUL IRISH: I'm making
it very mad.
Hey, we're just friends.
PAUL LEWIS: Did you
crash the browser?
PAUL IRISH: We can--
and you can--
come on.
Oh, it is really mad.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
you made it mad.
PAUL IRISH: This is
what I get for--
PAUL LEWIS: Turning me off.
The browser sided with me.
PAUL IRISH: Oh.
Let's kill that one.
Oh, that was the one that
I didn't-- oh, no.
PAUL LEWIS: You didn't
want that to happen.
PAUL IRISH: I didn't want
that to happen.
PAUL LEWIS: This goes to show,
profiling is not always the
easiest task [INAUDIBLE].
Sometimes these things break.
All right.
That looked good, looked
like you had it there.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
I think I got it.
So let's give this a shot.
We've got Timeline open.
I got this.
PAUL LEWIS: Maybe you
have to press a key.
PAUL IRISH: Play with me.
This is--
translate is trying
to take over.
I don't want you, translate.
PAUL LEWIS: We might need
to leave this one, then.
PAUL IRISH: Leaving it.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
PAUL IRISH: I just--
before a movie theater, there
was this preroll.
And it was advertising
movietickets.com.
And there was this really funny
ad, where the woman--
they're getting out
of the minivan.
And it's like a Mission
Impossible to get
to the movie tickets.
And then the kid falls getting
out of the minivan.
And the mom was like, leave
him, leave him.
And my mom really loves that
commercial, which--
PAUL LEWIS: I'm seeing
so much about your
upbringing right now.
In that 20 seconds, I didn't
expect that, if I'm honest.
Folks, I hope you enjoyed
that as much as I did.
Well.
PAUL IRISH: It's there.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
There's these paint
rectangles.
PAUL IRISH: Show Paint
Rectangles is on.
PAUL LEWIS: That's
probably why.
It's probably mad.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it's
really mad at us.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So we're going to move
to something else.
This is Behzad, designer
and developer.
Let's take a look.
So you can-- it says we can
use kind of the keys here.
Down.
PAUL LEWIS: This is looking
pretty good, right?
This is looking pretty--
PAUL IRISH: Wow.
Wow.
Someone hire this man.
All right.
There's this kind of
playful, kind of--
the background is parallaxing
two directions as these kind
of play a little bit.
PAUL LEWIS: And I'm seeing--
when I'm watching, say, the
phone here in this image, it's
kind of janking around.
It doesn't feel like
it's smooth motion.
PAUL IRISH: I don't know.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm wondering
about this.
PAUL IRISH: Do you think
we can improve it?
PAUL LEWIS: Well,
I don't know.
Let's find out what
it's doing.
PAUL IRISH: Honestly,
I think it's--
OK.
So let's--
PAUL LEWIS: See, I'm seeing
paints, right?
PAUL IRISH: It's all paint.
It's all paint.
Paint Recs is still on.
I'm going to make sure
that that's off.
We want that.
It's not going to
change anything.
It's all the same.
OK.
I'm using Command D. It's fast.
All right.
So we look in.
And we're all just--
we're in pain land.
PAUL LEWIS: Image resize!
PAUL IRISH: Image resize!
PAUL LEWIS: 50 milliseconds.
PAUL IRISH: Wow.
PAUL LEWIS: Who knew?
That's really good to know.
OK.
So image resize, unexpected.
PAUL LEWIS: So decoding and
resizing alike, there are
dependencies for paint.
So when Chrome hits something
that's it going to paint, it
goes, right, do I need
any images for this?
And it doesn't keep--
it keeps the PNG or the
JPEG in memory.
But it doesn't keep the bitmap
for that, the expanded,
decompressed version
of that in memory.
So it what it does, it goes
off on the fly and says,
right, decode and decompress
that image out to a bitmap.
And then resize it down.
So because we don't see a decode
here, something that
was already decoded in resident
memory, but it had to
be re-sized.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So it's this image, clearly.
PAUL LEWIS: You think?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm down with it.
PAUL IRISH: I don't really
know where it is.
But it's in here.
Are you in here?
Yup.
I'm using H to kind
of navigate the
DOM and hide parts.
It's in there?
Got it.
OK.
So oh, yeah.
Naturally, 220 pixels.
I mean, it's a big image.
PAUL LEWIS: 2,200, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
The larger the image, the more
expensive the resize will
cost, which makes sense.
But--
PAUL LEWIS: And this doesn't
actually make--
I mean, for me, I was
looking at this.
And it's not resizing.
It doesn't seem to
be resizing.
As you were moving, it was
moving left and top or
translating.
But it wasn't resizing.
So I wonder why there's
a resize going on.
PAUL IRISH: So it's
definitely--
yeah, left and tops.
PAUL LEWIS: So maybe something
is resizing it.
But it seems unusual to need
to resize it at all.
I guess what I'm driving at is
it could be served up that
size potentially, and the
problem would be solved.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, OK.
Let's--
PAUL LEWIS: I mean, just looking
at this profile.
I mean, this is all
green, right?
This is all paint work
that's happening.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
but I think--
I mean, it's triggered
off a mouse move.
There's a mouse move that's
watching the work.
Command uh--
PAUL LEWIS: Command
[INAUDIBLE]?
What are you doing?
PAUL IRISH: I'm really
interested in what happens
inside this image.
PAUL LEWIS: I don't blame you.
I'm fascinated, too.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm just
trying to--
PAUL IRISH: BG01.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
Because you're going quick.
And I'm wondering if people
are going to follow what
you're doing.
PAUL IRISH: Well, OK.
So I just found--
we grabbed the image.
PAUL LEWIS: Can I--
he's got--
PAUL IRISH: We're in the
mouse move, right?
We're in the mouse move, inside
this start screen.
So it looks like it's only just
mouse moves inside this
start screen, which
is good, rather
than the entire document.
PAUL LEWIS: Yup, yup, yup.
PAUL IRISH: But we re-grab
that element.
So we're doing a jQuery
traversal every single mouse
move, which we don't
need to, obviously.
We could cache that.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm seeing width and
height all over the place,
which feels like something
that wouldn't change.
PAUL IRISH: Width and height,
probably not going to change.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
I mean, that's only--
you could do those off of
requestAnimationFrame, off of
window resize.
PAUL IRISH: Then we just do a
bunch of math for the position
of the mouse and the current
width, height.
And then we just set the
left top to get the--
oh, it looks like he tried
some animation.
And that probably didn't
perform well.
PAUL LEWIS: It's interesting
that there's a--
oh, a failed 3D transform
document.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I would love
to know why that was--
PAUL IRISH: Come on.
Live edit, bro.
Live edit.
PAUL LEWIS: I would
love to know why--
that's smooth!
PAUL IRISH: That is smooth!
PAUL LEWIS: That's amazing.
PAUL IRISH: Let's go back.
OK, Timeline looked like this.
Command D. What the--
wait, wait.
There we go.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
PAUL LEWIS: That's--
PAUL IRISH: Seems better.
PAUL LEWIS: That seems better.
PAUL LEWIS: That's breaking
through less often.
Switch it back.
All right.
So we're seeing 60
frames a second.
Boom.
Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: I bet this was
all set up for us.
PAUL LEWIS: I kno.
It genuinely wasn't.
That's the best bit of this.
OK, yeah
PAUL IRISH: I don't know
what's going on.
PAUL LEWIS: That doesn't
feel like--
all right.
Is that doing the right thing?
Did you save the change?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, yeah, I did.
PAUL LEWIS: Are you sure?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, I'm sure.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
PAUL IRISH: Here, I'm going to--
this is probably a better
way to do it.
PAUL LEWIS: You're
going to relead?
PAUL IRISH: No, I'm
not reloading.
Start, move.
[HUMMING]
Come over here.
Sources, quick, quick,
quick, quick, quick.
Save, patch to the [INAUDIBLE].
Come back.
And, and, go, and--
hard to say.
PAUL LEWIS: Very hard to say,
based on what you just did.
PAUL IRISH: It does--
I mean, at first glance,
it looked like--
I mean, you saw what
I did, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
PAUL IRISH: I mean,
it was just fast.
PAUL LEWIS: It was
just, [YELLS].
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Well, sorry.
It does--
OK.
PAUL LEWIS: That's what it's
like working with Paul Irish.
PAUL IRISH: I think
I was making--
PAUL LEWIS: Some people
are slow.
Some people are fast.
And then there's Paul Irish.
PAUL IRISH: I-- yeah.
So it looks like it actually
was more costly.
PAUL LEWIS: I would be
interested in spending a bit
more time on this if
I were the author.
PAUL IRISH: I think Behzad--
he tried it.
And he saw this.
And then he went back and went
like, I'm just going to set
left top, which is cray-cray
because--
[LAUGHING]
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Anyways.
PAUL LEWIS: But I
still think--
for me, I would look at the
3D transform again.
It seems like that might be
the better option here.
It's hard to say for sure.
But it seems like it might
be worth trying.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
The other thing I think that's
probably important is--
we keep asking about the width
and height of this image.
And it might that which is
causing the size, like the
browser is not terribly
confident in what
the actual size is.
And so it's going
to ask again.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
I mean, there's no reason to
keep querying the width and
height there.
I think that's definitely
something to take a look at.
That's monster.
That is monster big, isn't it?
PAUL IRISH: All right.
The other thing--
yeah.
We should--
you want to show a continuous
paint on any of this?
PAUL LEWIS: I don't know.
PAUL IRISH: So it's
hard to say.
So these paints are big.
And so we can go in and
turn on Continuous
Paint Mode down here.
And I'll just re-dock
my DevTools.
And so what it's going to do
is it's just going to paint
the page again and
again and again.
And up here in the top right
of the page, we'll see how
long it takes to paint.
And from here, we can just
toggle things on and off.
Or you can use the H key.
So I turned off the
background.
And the paint performance
improves a little bit.
PAUL LEWIS: It's not
noticeably so.
PAUL IRISH: Not dramatically.
PAUL LEWIS: So this
is-- so this taps
into the other thing.
When we were talking about paint
areas before, that's
like part one.
Part two is paint complexity,
which is what this tool's
trying to show.
It's like if Chrome starts from
nothing, and it's got to
paint everything that's on
screen, how long does that
process take?
So it's kind of fluctuating,
what?
Roughly between somewhere
around the eight to
10 mark, I'd say.
Which means it's not
terribly complex to
repaint at this point.
PAUL IRISH: It's not that bad.
I mean, it could
be much better.
PAUL LEWIS: It could be worse.
But sometimes you'll see huge
spikes in the actual paint
time from when it's painting
from scratch.
PAUL IRISH: So I want
to try one thing.
Here.
We're going to turn on--
I like doing Composite Layer
Borders at the same time as
Paint Recs.
PAUL LEWIS: You've got Show
Paint Rectangles on.
PAUL IRISH: Do I?
PAUL LEWIS: I think.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, yeah.
We have Show Paint Recs.
PAUL LEWIS: But you
haven't got--
PAUL IRISH: Layer borders.
PAUL LEWIS: You need to switch
on the first layer--
PAUL IRISH: Thank you.
Thank you.
OK.
Nothing's promoted.
This is what I was thinking.
I was thinking of promoting
these navs.
Terrible?
PAUL LEWIS: I don't know.
PAUL IRISH: I don't know.
PAUL LEWIS: Let's find out.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
This guy.
Yup, yup, yup.
Webkit transform--
PAUL LEWIS: So the reason I
would assume you're doing this
is because it's over the
top of something else.
PAUL IRISH: It's opacity.
PAUL LEWIS: And you're concerned
that it's grouping
them together into a single
bitmap in memory.
And you want to break it
down to its own layer.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Because in Timeline, we did
see a good amount of
compositing costs, like
this composite layers.
And I'm guessing that because
these nav items have an
opacity on them, it's having to
do the compositing against
the background on every
single move.
So I'm guessing that if we drop
them out into layers--
PAUL LEWIS: Yup.
Then it's just-- all it's got to
do is it's got to just let
the GPU deal with that for us.
PAUL IRISH: That seems
pretty nice-ish.
PAUL LEWIS: You want
to profile it?
PAUL IRISH: I'll profile it.
PAUL LEWIS: Don't guess it.
PAUL IRISH: Test it.
PAUL LEWIS: Perfect.
I couldn't have asked for--
you're just the best.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
I turned off those
two debug modes.
And I'll turn it back on.
Oh, come on!
Nailed it!
Yeah!
PAUL LEWIS: And that's
how we do it.
PAUL IRISH: That was good.
PAUL LEWIS: This is genuinely
how we do this.
This is why we didn't
look at these too
closely before we started.
Hey, do you want to talk about
the transparent frame thing a
little bit?
PAUL IRISH: Oh, yeah, yeah.
OK.
So I'm going to start.
And then you--
OK.
If you're in timeline a lot,
you're going to see--
so these vertical bars, right?
And there's color at the bottom
of them, of course.
But then there's empty space.
There is this little dark
gray area here.
And that represents
uninstrumented code.
So we know that Chrome is doing
work, but we're not
exactly sure what
kind of work.
We're improving that.
PAUL LEWIS: So gray should
disappear over time.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
But then there's this case where
there's this kind of
this empty area leading
up to the 60 fps line.
PAUL LEWIS: Now, we don't
care about those, right?
PAUL IRISH: It doesn't matter.
That part really is
not a big concern.
You are hitting your
frame budget.
And Chrome's responsibility here
is to deliver a frame on
the Vsync of the monitor, which
means every time the
monitor's going to bring a frame
to my eyes, it wants to
have something ready for it.
PAUL LEWIS: So this
is room to spare,
basically, what we're seeing.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Empty space is like
Chrome saying, I'm done.
I can chill out until the
end of this frame.
But then there's the odd
frame that we're
seeing here, which is--
PAUL IRISH: This guy
PAUL LEWIS: Which is shooting
out of the top.
PAUL IRISH: And it is
all empty space.
And so there's two things
to look at here.
One is--
so you see these gray bars
that are kind of in my
Timeline view?
PAUL LEWIS: No, you can switch
those on, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So inside Settings, somewhere
down here is showing CPU
activity on the ruler.
And so it's off by default.
You'll have to turn it on.
But here, you'll get an idea
of, is the CPU active?
If the CPU is active-- maybe
something outside of Chrome is
doing a lot of work, which is
why Chrome had to slow down--
so you get an idea on what kind
of work is being done.
PAUL LEWIS: So the thing to do
here is to make sure-- if
you're going to do these
profiles, and you see
something like this, and you
want to just rule out other
apps, do that.
Close them down.
Make sure Chrome is the only
thing that's running.
Ideally, if you can really
do it, just go
into Incognito Mode.
Make sure this is the
only thing that's
running in the tab.
So it's just as isolated
as it can be.
PAUL IRISH: Kill all of the
tabs, Incognito, no
extensions.
PAUL LEWIS: It's
the only thing.
Yeah, nothing.
So it's just running
by itself.
So that kind of, as best as you
can, is going to eliminate
the kind of vying for
the CPU's attention.
PAUL IRISH: But in this case,
I do not have CPU activity
exactly there.
I mean, it's right here.
Right here and right here.
So what's--
can you tell me more about
what's going on here?
PAUL LEWIS: Sometimes it's going
to be Chrome waiting on
GPU, the simple version
of this.
It's just Chrome saying, I need
the GPU to do its work,
do some composting for example,
just deal with some
stuff, finish its workload.
And that, at the moment, is
currently showing as empty.
So sometimes it's just
simply-- and again,
it might not be--
we've only got one GPU normally
in these things.
So it might not be Chrome that's
waiting on the GPU.
But it might be something else
on your system that's actually
using the GPU.
So don't always assume
it's the browser.
But it can be waiting on
CPU and waiting on GPU.
PAUL IRISH: So one use case you
mentioned to me about this
was a lot of times in a WebGL
situation, you might be
uploading textures to the GPU.
Uploading textures to the GPU
generally can take a good
amount of time--
PAUL LEWIS: Especially
on on mobile
PAUL IRISH: --especially
on mobile.
So that might be an indication
of something that might be
happening here.
I should point out that this
is something that DevTools
will get better at.
And we'll be able to help give
you more insight into what
time is being absorbed
here and why.
For now, that's a--
PAUL LEWIS: I don't think
there's anything as a
developer that's directly
actionable
typically here as well.
If you're not dealing with WebGL
or Canvas or something
that's super GPU heavy, then
the chances are, it's just
something to do with Chrome's
overhead, probably the most
likely candidate.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: I think that's--
I think we--
should we finish?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
let's finish.
PAUL IRISH: Thank you very
much for watching.
If you want to dig in more into
these tools and what's
available, you can just
Google DevTools.
The Chrome DevTools
documentation will come up.
It talks a lot about Timeline,
continuous paint,
and things like that.
We also just posted about a
lot of the new features on
HTML5rocks.com, including-- we
didn't show the flame chart.
PAUL LEWIS: You want to just--
give us a minute.
We'll show you a flame chart.
PAUL IRISH: Flame chart,
flame chart.
PAUL LEWIS: He loves
the flame chart.
I-- to be fair, Paul requested
It was his feature request.
PAUL IRISH: Come on.
PAUL LEWIS: He loved it.
He's so happy.
I'm so happy for him.
PAUL IRISH: It is
my feature area.
PAUL LEWIS: It's
just the best.
PAUL IRISH: I'll give a really
good example for the flame
char too because it's
just worth it.
PAUL LEWIS: Even
if he says so.
PAUL IRISH: Come over
to your MathJax.
It's a MathML polyfill.
We're going to bring up
DevTools really quick.
And I'm going to start
a CPU profile.
So flame chart is a
visualization of
a JavaScript profile.
Start, change to SVG rendering,
[STUTTERING]
go.
Change to HTML rendering, go.
SVG, go.
Boom, done.
Command D. OK, awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: Now, it won't be
flame chart by default,
though, right?
No.
PAUL LEWIS: You have
to switch this on.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Down at the very bottom
is the toggle.
So it'll be probably
heavy bottom up.
And this is the one
that everyone's
used to seeing, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Which to be fair, is
pretty difficult for a lot
of people to kind understand
and get that.
PAUL IRISH: I think so too.
I think so too.
PAUL LEWIS: Which is why you
suggested the flame chart.
PAUL IRISH: Hey-o.
Flame chart.
So we've got a flame
chart here.
So the cool thing here is
it's Timeline based.
So we're seeing from the
beginning of my reporting to
the seven seconds
that I recorded.
And we can see that in the
mini map-- so this is the
first time that it's
changed to SVG.
And I know because I've looked
at this before, there's a lot
of interrupted CPU activity.
This is because there's network
activity kind of
interrupting this.
That's something that-- but once
I had it in place, you
can see it's just straight
up stuff going on.
Let me try and maximize this
a little bit more.
I'm going to have to
zoom out of touch.
There is a lot of stuff
going on here.
And the way to parse
these graphs is
y-axis is call stack.
Call stack is not a bad thing.
It's not a bad thing that
your call stack
is necessarily deep.
So height is not terribly
important.
Width is what soaks up time.
PAUL LEWIS: Because this
is time, right?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, exactly.
Tighter on the--
PAUL LEWIS: The longer
it is, right?
PAUL IRISH: Longer is worse.
PAUL LEWIS: Normally.
PAUL IRISH: [LAUGHS]
OK.
And so we can kind
of scroll in.
I can zoom by just going up
and down on the track pad.
I can also page just by
dragging over here.
And we can take a look at kind
of where my time was spent.
And the other nice thing is
that we can understand a
little bit about the execution
flow of the application by
seeing that things
started off.
We went into Set Mode rendering
in MathJax.
And we did a little bit of
prep work right here.
We moved into this
removeChild.
This is doing some SVG work.
This removeChild took six
milliseconds, which is a
pretty long time.
PAUL LEWIS: So I'll tell you
what because this is quite
different when you're looking
at these things and it's not
your own code.
If you run this against your
own code, you're going to
recognize the functions.
You're going to recognize
the objects.
You'll recognize everything
you see here.
And you're going to be like,
oh wow, I didn't realize it
was spending so long
doing that
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So flame chart.
PAUL LEWIS: Awesome.
PAUL IRISH: Good.
Very useful when you identify
that you are spending a lot of
time in JavaScript
in particular.
It's not appropriate when you
see that you're spending time
in paint, layout, recalc style,
things like that, but
should help quite a bit.
PAUL LEWIS: Which is
always the case.
Find your actual bottleneck
and fix that one, not the
thing you think is
the bottleneck.
PAUL IRISH: [SNAPS FINGERS]
PAUL LEWIS: Should
we close on that?
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Boom.
PAUL IRISH: Boom.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you.